-Welcome back to the show,
everybody.
Give it up once again
for our bandleader tonight,
Robert Glasper in the house.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ooh! Different color vinyl
right here.
Ooh, look at this.
Ooh. Come on.
I saw Robert at the Blue Note
not too long ago,
a couple of weeks ago,
and it was phenomenal.
You were so great.
-Thank you.
-It's just if you ever
get a chance to see Robert --
well, you are seeing him live --
but to just see the whole
experience, the whole thing,
I've never seen
anything like it.
Who's your deejay?
-Jahi Sundance.
-Oh, my gosh, he was so great.
And he's deejaying
as you're doing
and you're playing jazz.
And it's just -- it's like,
you don't know what kind of
is going to happen next.
And at one point you started,
like, whistling
in the song and you're like...
[ Whistles ]
And you did it. And it kind
of worked perfectly.
And I go, "Wow,
this guy is brilliant."
And then the song ended.
I don't know if you remember
this. It made me laugh.
You started whistle
conversationing with him.
-Oh, that's right. That's right.
-You you were like,
you started going like...
[ Laughs ]
I can't do it while I'm
laughing, but you're like...
[ Whistling ]
-[ Whistling ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Whistles ]
-[ Whistling ]
♪♪
[ Both whistling ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Whistling continuing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪